y reclamaron por venir
con piedra la última gran leyenda de la
música ranchera su sello una potente voz
y un gran dominio del escenario
[Música]
[Aplausos]
de familia humilde nació un 17 de
febrero de 1940 en huentitán el alto
jalisco a una temprana edad trabajo de
mariachi antes de firmar en 1966 con lo
que hoy es la discográfica sony unos
comienzos que el propio vicente
recordaba así todos los años
más de 100 álbumes grabados y más de 65
millones de discos vendidos cuenta con
ocho grammys latinos y tres grammys
anglo una prolífica producción musical
que lo convirtió en una estrella en
varios países de américa latina
participó en 25 películas y también
cuenta con su estrella en el paseo de la
fama de hollywood lujo que comparte con
su hijo y uno de sus herederos alejandro
fernández
espera
[Música]
para el corazón
con una faceta también como empresario
productor en sus últimos años fue
señalado y expuesto en imágenes por
acoso sexual y tocamientos a mujeres al
igual que unas polémicas declaraciones
en las que rechazó un trasplante de
hígado por temor a que el donante fuera
homosexual o drogadicto su muerte es el
fin de una era en méxico dentro de un
olimpo musical en el que ya están otros
grandes nombres como josé alfredo
jiménez jorge negrete pedro infante
javier solís o juan gabriel
[Aplausos]